tu fais mes thèmes une année en panda
j'aimerais que vous êtes mignonne avec
vos piles au mas d'animaux disparus
mais moi j'ai pas du tout disent pas ou
les hommes me trouve beaucoup trop
mignonne oh ça va
le melon là ça se passe comment mais non
ça n'a rien à voir
début 2019 est sorti un article
compilant les résultats de 73 études
publiées depuis 40 ans sur l'état de la
biodiversité et le constat est alarmant
aujourd'hui environ un tiers des espèces
sont menacées d'extinction et chaque
année environ 1% supplémentaire s'ajoute
à la liste
mais si je vous demande de me citer une
espèce menacée vous me suis très
sûrement
l'ours polaire le tigre peut-être le
panda bref des mammifères mignon est
emblématique
et ce n'est pas anodin ces espèces sont
ce que l'on appelle des espèces
charismatique le biologiste franck
courchamp c'est justement attaché à
définir une liste de ces espèces qui
profite d'une grande visibilité
médiatique
il a d'abord demandé aux internautes de
lisser ces animaux puis il a posé la
même question à des écoliers en
angleterre en espagne et en france et
enfin il a répertorié tous les animaux
sauvages qui était sur les affiches des
films d'animation disney pixar et
dreamworks ainsi que tous les animaux
figurant sur la page d'accueil des eaux
des 100 plus grandes villes du monde
résultat les dix animaux sauvages les
plus charismatiques sont le tigre le
lion l'éléphant la girafe le léopard le
panda le guépard l'ours polaire le loup
et le gorille
sauf qu'il y a tout un autre pan de la
biodiversité souvent oubliés qui
disparaît aujourd'hui en silence les
insectes
au total sur la base de tous ces études
les auteurs montrent que la proportion
d'espèces en déclin s'élève à 41 % pour
les insectes soit une proportion deux
fois plus grande que les vertébrés et
les causes principales du déclin des
insectes sont clairement établies la
disparition des milieux naturels par
l'agriculture et l'urbanisation les
polluants fertilisants en pesticides
dexter les facteurs biologiques
introductions d'espèces envahissantes ou
de pathogènes et enfin le changement
climatique
mais voilà qui s'émeut du déclin les
insectes qui milite pour la sauvegarde
des termites ou des mouches pourtant
leur disparition entraîne
irrémédiablement la disparition de leurs
prédateurs cause des problèmes de
pollinisation
d'appauvrissement des sols et c est ce
que nous n'aurions pas un biais dans nos
choix de sauvegarde de la biodiversité
oui je suis en train de me demander si
on n'aurait pas tendance à sauvegarder
certaines espèces juste parce qu'on les
trouve mignonne sans tenir compte de
leur importance dans l'écosystème une
équipe de chercheurs français a
justement essayer de voir si notre
perception de la beauté du vivant était
en accord avec les fonctions écologiques
des espèces l'équipe du biologiste
nicolas bouquet a mis au point une
méthode permettant de mesurer la valeur
esthétique des poissons tropicaux
ils ont demandé à plus de 8000 personnes
de 3 à 80 ans de choisir entre deux
photos de poissons l'espèce qu'il
trouvait la plus belle ils ont ensuite
évalué le rôle de chaque espèce dans
l'écosystème en fonction de ses
caractéristiques
ils ont ainsi pu montrer que les espèces
les plus belles les plus attractives aux
yeux des personnes consultées joue
rarement un rôle clé dans l'écosystème
plus précisément les espèces les moins
jolie étaient 33 % plus utiles à
l'écosystème que les espèces les plus
jolies cette recherche s'est transformé
en une étude participatif plus vaste et
s'étend désormais aux insectes et aux
orchidées
d'ailleurs si vous voulez y participer
le lien est en descriptions
[Musique]
car allons c'est carrément un biais
cognitifs en fait on peut pas se baser
juste sur le côté esthétique des animaux
s'ils sont bons ou pas le fait d'être
mignon ben ça change rien sur la
position d'un écosystème sur ça doit
changer dans l'évolution des espèces
pense que ça doit être un avantage
évolutif à être mignon ou plutôt le
contraire
king goldbach 2016
la mignonne études ça se passe dans le
cerveau des parents cette étude la dcri
que tu sais pas tellement les animaux
qui ont été sélectionnés de plus en plus
mignon c'est plutôt le cerveau des
parents qui a subi une pression
évolutive
car les parents qui étaient du genre à
trouver leurs enfants plus mignon sans
sont plus occupés ils ont eu plus de
chance de survie alors que les groupes
sociaux qui étaient moins du genre à
trouver leur bébé mignon laisser crever
probablement troqué oui donc du coup
c'est un avantage évolutif de trois
essais un avantage évolutif de trouver
ses propres enfants mignons ça aide à
perpétuer ces génies d'accord et parmi
les espèces qui sont mignonnes
aujourd'hui il ya les animaux
domestiques par exemple les chiens les
chats qu'on a aujourd'hui il n'existait
pas à la préhistoire
c'est plutôt les loups qui se sont auto
domestique et ceux qui avaient des têtes
les moins repoussante qui était un peu
les plus mignons
bah du coup ils ont eu un avantage
évolutif qui n'était plus acceptée dans
les communautés humaines et du coup ils
n'ont plus pu profiter des restes des
êtres humains et du coup là c'est
clairement il valait mieux être mignon
pour survivre à ce moment-là précis pour
un loup il valait carrément mieux être
mignon pour survivre et puis après coup
l'espèce humaine a carrément pris les
choses en main on a fait se reproduire
déportés et on a choisi les individus
les plus mignons les plus dociles pour
pouvoir se faire reproduire et en
quelques milliers d'années
l'espèce a carrément évoluer jusqu'au
petit chihuahua trop mignon avec les
couettes qu'on a aujourd'hui
cependant pour ça que guichet il est
aussi mignon aujourd'hui on peut aussi
se demander si du côté des études en
biologie
certains animaux ne concentrerait pas
plus l'attention que d'autres le bio
informaticiens julien troudet a
récemment essayé de quantifier ce biais
à partir des données du système mondial
d'information sur la biodiversité
cette bibliothèque open access et
participative rassemblent au niveau
mondial des données sur la présence et
la localisation des êtres vivants
depuis les spécimens recensés dans les
musées jusqu'aux photos géolocalisées
des naturalistes amateurs
ces données sont la matière première
utilisée dans tous les domaines de la
recherche en biodiversité
l'analyse de plus de 600 millions de
données animales et végétales a montré
de grands écarts entre les espèces
répertoriées
il y à plus de 370 donné par espèce pour
la moitié des oiseaux et seulement 3
donné par espèce pour la moitié des
insectes les chercheurs formulent donc
une hypothèse sociétale au delà des
facteurs pratique genre facilité
d'observation accès au terrain tension
de financement les organismes les plus
étudiées serait ce préféré par la
population double peine donc pour les
animaux moche non seulement le grand
public et les politiques sont moins
investi dans les programmes de
sauvegarde mais en plus ils sont moins
étudiés sauf que ce sont sur ces
connaissances que doivent s'appuyer les
programmes de conservation de la
biodiversité
à ce jour les scientifiques ont
répertorié environ deux millions
d'espèces vivantes
ce qui ne correspond en fait qu'à une
toute petite partie la biodiversité
réellement présentes sur terre selon les
biologistes paul ollivier et michael lee
le nombre d'espèces sur terre serait
plus proche de 100 millions
déjà parce qu'on connaît encore très mal
la biodiversité des micro-organismes
mais aussi parce que la plus grande
partie des espèces répertoriées jusqu'à
présent est basé sur une description
morphologique des individus les analyses
adn permettent désormais de distinguer
deux nouvelles espèces car chacune
représente un patrimoine génétique
particulier qui évoluent indépendamment
le cas extrêmes ce sont les espèces
cryptic
extérieurement les individus sont très
semblables sauf qu'en réalité ils
appartiennent à des groupes différents
qui ne se reproduise jamais entre eux et
manque de pot en croisant les études
génétiques écologique et de terrain un
grand nombre d'espèces décrites jusqu'à
présent se révèle être constitué de
plusieurs espèces cryptic par exemple
les scientifiques viennent tout juste de
réaliser que les éléphants africains qui
sont pourtant des espèces charismatique
ne sont probablement pas une seule et
même espèce mais deux espèces cryptic
l'éléphant la savane et l'éléphant de la
forêt et il ne s'agit pas seulement
d'obtenir le nombre exact d'espèce les
lacunes dans notre connaissance de la
biodiversité pourrait avoir des
répercussions sur notre méthode de
conservation
pour reprendre l'exemple de l'éléphant
ne sachant pas qu'il s'agit de deux
espèces distinctes
nous pourrions choisir de laisser mourir
les éléphants dans la forêt tant que
nous envoyons dans la savane % qu'il
s'agit simplement d'un déplacement de la
rabita et en essayant de réintroduire
dans la forêt des éléphants de la savane
nous serions surpris de voir qu'ils ne
se reproduisent pas entre la solution
serait donc de médiatiser et promouvoir
les espèces moins charismatique c'est
une tâche qui pourraient incomber plutôt
aux chercheurs mais il faut également
que le grand public s'ouvre à leur
charme particulier et au récit
passionnant les concernant les
spécialistes du ver de terre par exemple
les géo driot log comme le népal ont pu
attirer l'attention sur ces petits
animaux dans la population a été divisée
par dix depuis les années 50
la campagne de communication sauvons le
ver de terre à réhabiliter ces
invertébrés aveugle sourd et biscuits en
montrant combien ils sont indispensables
à la bonne santé des sols
mais même en rendant certains animaux
méconnus plus visible dans les médias ça
n'est pas gagné
au contraire même en réalisant ses
études sur les animaux charismatique le
biologiste franck courchamp à noter que
les gens avaient une très mauvaise
perception du danger d'extinction
encourus par ces animaux
saviez vous que les lions pourraient
disparaître dans 20 ans si rien n'est
fait ou que la girafe est une espèce en
voie de disparition
selon le chercheur le fait de voir
autant de girafes et d'autres animaux
charismatique dans les médias donner
l'impression que ces espèces ne sont pas
en danger
du coup est ce que la science de la
conservation font ce qu'il faut pour
encourager la sauvegarde de la
biodiversité
les chercheurs laurent gaudé et vincent
de victor ont analysé le
venus de treize mille articles publiés
entre 2000 et 2015 par les biologistes
de la conservation
après avoir mis de côté les articles de
discussions internes à la discipline
ils ont classé les études en trois
catégories l'état de la biodiversité les
menaces qui pèsent sur celles ci et les
solutions possibles
bon sur l'état de la biodiversité sa
patte surprise le tableau est
globalement négatif mais le côté positif
est que cette enquête identifie 14 types
de mesures différentes efficace et
montre que les solutions durables et
compatible avec les activités humaines
existent on peut restaurer des
écosystèmes tout en maintenant de
l'agriculture par exemple en ne déviant
que partiellement un cours d'eau le
frein majeur reste la demande de
compromis toujours plus favorable à
l'exploitation plutôt qu'à la
conservation
il faut donc maintenant que les
solutions scientifiques diffusent dans
la société vers le grand public et les
décideurs politiques
finalement même si on ne doit pas s'en
contenter pour définir nos politiques de
conservation de la biodiversité notre
sensibilité esthétique peut tout de même
être un moteur à notre envie de protéger
le vivant c'est la conclusion de la
philosophe de l'environnement virginie
marys il n'y a pas que ce qui est beau
et que ceux qui nous émeut qui mérite
une certaine considération
merci à vous les minions d'avoir
regarder cet épisode du vortex abonnez
vous laissez un commentaire rejoignez
nous sur le discorde et je vous dis à
très vite
[Musique]
les a je pense que tu va survivre toi